super sonnenstürme führen zu höheren
schäden als gedacht dass diese super
songs stürme sind unausweichlich alle
100 bis 200 jahre wird die erde wohl von
einem getroffen und was bisher keiner
für möglich gehalten hat die schäden
gehen in die milliarden
das projekt bike x1 entwickeln ein
sonnensturm ist eine eruption auf der
sonnenoberfläche bei der magnetische
plasma in den weltraum geschleudert wird
elektronen und protonen trifft dieses
pack mal die erde wird das magnetfeld
gestaucht und kosmische strahlung trifft
die atmosphäre und sogar tiefere
schichten wunderschöne polarlichter sind
sogar am äquator zu sehen durch die
moderne technik von der unser leben
überall auf unserem planeten abhängt
sind wir allerdings äußerst verwundbar
ein solches ereignis stört und sein
ganzes elektrisches netzwerke fängt bei
den gps satelliten an hier stören die
von der sonne ausgebrochenen elektronen
und protonen die direkte satelliten und
unser navi spielen verrückt am boden
werden durch das zusammen quetschen des
magnetfeldes riesige ströme induziert
die die elektrischen geräte zerstörung
flächendeckend ganze regionen können
durch einen einzigen sonnensturm
lahmgelegt werden zitat solche
superstimme können satelliten gps den
zugverkehr und die elektrischen netze
lahmlegen
auch die unbewirtschaftete und
gesellschaft angewiesen ist vor allem
ein ausfall des stromnetzes
problematisch weil die seine ganze
kaskade von anderen davon abhängigen
infrastrukturen betreffen kann erklärte
edward orten von der university of
cambridge im fachmagazin nature wurde
jetzt neue hochrechnungen veröffentlicht
die die folgen einer kollision zwischen
erde und sonne sturm in zahlen
ausdrücken wir in den grafiken weht
simulierten die wissenschaftler vier
verschiedene ereignisse
bezogen auf die vereinigten staaten von
amerika wer denkt ja ist ja nur amerika
der liegt falsch denn die orten weiter
berichtet machen die direkt durch den
stromausfall verursachten
wirtschaftlichen kosten nur rund 49
prozent der gesamten schäden und
einbußen
aus greffen sonnensturm den 50
breitengrad amerika würden dass fast die
hälfte aller amerikaner zu spüren
bekommen alle 24 stunden würde einen
schaden von mehr als 37 milliarden
us-dollar entstehen
wie schlimm ist und weltweit treffen
würde kann man aktuell noch nicht sagen
zum einen dauert ein sonnensturm mit
exakt 24 stunden und zum anderen fehlen
studien zu den folgen in europa und
anderen kontinenten in welcher
preisspanne denkt ihr könnte man den
internationalen schaden innerhalb eines
tages einordnen lassen eure vorschläge
un-schätzungen mal in den kommentaren
ich bin gespannt und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann freue ich mich über
genau das hier und ein abo dafür da
klicken und das nächste video gibt es
hier und ansonsten bis dann bleibt da
nicht gibt